in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jim is
live and in person on our millionaire
theme our Jim what's your net worth sir
well we are new to the millionaire
number so as of December 29th and we
crossed that and as of today I look at
it every day it's 1 million forty
thousand seven hundred eighty two
dollars ha you are you just broke the
plane look at you I love it man
very cool and how's that broken down
tell me the breakdown on it it's almost
exactly a third in each so about three
hundred thirty in cash about 350 and
investments in about three hundred fifty
thousand in property okay is your house
paid for yes sir we were here five years
ago next week to do our debt free scream
when we paid the house off good for you
how old are you 39 our young millionaire
for the day
all right good and how much of the
million forty thousand is there because
you inherited the money and it made you
rich so my wife did inherit fourteen
thousand dollars this this past year and
my parents were just generous enough at
some point they they gave us ten
thousand dollars as a Christmas present
never never done anything like that
before so I guess total you'd say twenty
four thousand dollars of that but really
that's you were already a millionaire
almost right so they didn't cause you to
be rich correct okay all right and
you're a household income
top at best and worst year so worst has
been at the very bottom when we when we
first met got married our household net
worth our household income was less than
a hundred thousand and I'm happy to say
that this year we hit our be hag and
it's three hundred and thirty thousand
good for you well done love it what do
you do for a living so my wife is in
medical field she's a CRA manager of CRA
and then I work locally for absolute
Wireless we're a sprint retailer and
I've got a fantastic team that supports
me and do great things
what do you do so I'm the sales manager
okay shows manager yes sir do you have a
four-year degree I do not my wife does
but I do not what is her Sam it's
actually in her field she's in
the job that she she went to school for
and what was your GPA in high school
high school three point three probably
okay hers in college or high school
either one I would say probably about
the same okay all right cool and how
much of the million dollars is there
because you borrowed money to create
well zero okay cool and you told me in
the break I was out the commercial
breaks on your book and everything that
you guys have been through on trade
leadership yes sir so we we went to a
tea MMO event years and years ago and we
got on fire and that's what set us on
this pace I went through an entree
leadership one day actually was the one
you had on April 1st years ago and then
I believe it was 2011 or - yeah 2011
January when you were TM mo here in
Nashville I'm sorry and then we went
2011 was entre leadership and so I went
through the nothing I guess new master
series but the ones you guys held here
gotcha okay so Daniel and his team
they're rock stars yeah very cool Chris
that's fantastic so do you and your wife
do you all do giving we do it's not
really structured it's just when you
know our heart tells us that we should
my dad is very involved in in helping
veterans so sometimes it's related to
that okay so very good and what's the
most you've ever paid for a pair of
jeans honestly I do not own a pair of
jeans as crazy as it may sound I do not
have a pair of jeans at the moment about
your wife I would say probably somewhere
around 30 or 40 dollars okay all right
and have you ever bought a new car you
or your wife we have so as a 17 year old
I bought a new car and then fast forward
as a I guess young professional I bought
a new car neither one of those was over
$17,000 and then we did buy my wife a
new car about three years ago okay then
once you started winning again yeah all
right good good so let me ask you this
you're 39 years old you're a millionaire
you're not quite a millennial you're
really a gin wire I guess you're a young
millionaire so speak to these young
people the 20 to 30 year old is this
possible and if so tell them what they
should do to get there
it's not just possible I almost look at
it like you have to like our our goal in
our house was before my 40th birthday
which is next week to hit that number
and so we were just driving striving
striving but we didn't get really still
we didn't get started until we were in
our 30s we didn't we didn't really start
getting traction so if I was gonna tell
somebody young pay attention to the
older ones plus with the gray hair pay a
little bit more attention get started
early and then be about whatever you're
passionate about I'm passionate about my
family I'm passionate about my team and
we move mountains because we have
passion and it's kind of like your team
here Dave I mean it's not you with the
passion it's the passion that's in all
of your entire team moving in the same
direction that gives you the the oomphel
that you need and so tell people your
dreams tell people what you're about and
they'll help you get there don't keep it
private put it out there and and get be
about the business of getting it done
what's the best nan Ramsey book you read
in the last year actually just finished
up kin Blanchard's one minute manager
meets the monkey oh yeah so very cool
yes sir ken just did a compilation of
leadership book with a bunch of
different leaders speaking into it I did
a chapter for it that just came out I
think last month well fantastic he's a
friend he's a good guy good stuff
hey man thank you for dropping by
congratulations to fantail of it I love
it love it I do Dave man 39 39 year old
Megan it's a game changer
game changer what why are we doing this
we're doing this for you the listener to
tell you you can do this this is the
Dave Ramsey show